the state of public education is under
scrutiny once again as another major
teacher strike gets underway seattle's
first day of school is canceled with
teachers hitting the picket line today
they want more pay they also want better
conditions for their students l thomas
of our seattle station cairo has more on
this story
i'm kind of sad because i was excited
for my first day of school i understand
why they're doing it i mean teachers
don't get paid that much better pays
smaller class sizes and mental health
resources are all issues on the
bargaining table for seattle public
school teachers sps has given us no
choice jennifer motter is the union
president
we can't continue
that same status quo it's unsustainable
it's leading to educator burnout where
students needs are not being met
it's a sentiment shared nationwide a
recent survey of public school teachers
found that 90
said burnout is a serious problem and
there are at least 280 thousand fewer
public school teachers working now than
before the pandemic
this is unprecedented the level of
trauma that we're seeing in our
populations and just the amount of work
that we have to do now
after coming back from the pandemic we
take this moment seriously the district
superintendent said negotiators are
working hard to come to a resolution
seeking agreement should not result in
extra stress for our students family
staff and community teachers agree but
argue the strike is a necessary step
toward putting the community first
we understand the impact that has on
families
i wouldn't be here if what the district
was proposing was not unconscionable
the district did propose
percentage-based wage hikes for teachers
who called those increases significantly
smaller than their demands a
spokesperson said the district was
disappointed with the decision to strike
but added that it was still committed to
negotiating on a new contract vlad
well thomas great reporting thank you
very much